which expressions are equivalent to two
times the quantity four f plus two g
mark all that apply so the first one
here is eight f plus four g so could i
manipulate this somehow in a valid way
so i get eight f plus four g well the
most obvious thing is i just distribute
the two so two times this whole quantity
is going to be two times four f
two times four f
plus
two times two g
which is equal to
eight f
plus
four g so these this this expression is
indeed equivalent to that expression
right over there
now let's see what they tried to do two
f times this thing right over here is
that equivalent to that over there
well it doesn't look like it's going to
be and you can even try to distribute
this right over here you're going to get
if we distribute the 2f you'll get 2f
times 4 is
f and two f times two g is
plus four f g which is very different
than
eight f plus four g this is this is
eight f plus four f of g so this one is
not
this one is not an equivalent expression
and here that you have 8f plus 2g well
8f plus 2g we already know is different
than 8f plus 4g and 8f plus 4g is an
equivalent expression and these two
things aren't equivalent so we can cross
that out now they have a 4 times 2f plus
g
well what happens if we were to factor 4
out of 8f plus 4g which we already know
is equivalent to our original expression
so if you try to factor out a 4 right
over here so you divide 8 by four you
get two f
and you divide four g by four you get g
and you can't just only divide by four
then you then have to multiply by four
in order to not change the actual value
of the expression so all we did is we
divided by four and then multiplied by
four which doesn't change the actual
value or you could think of it as we
undistributed a four we factored out a
four so four times two f plus four g is
indeed the same thing as eight f plus
four g which is we already know is the
same thing as our original expression
and you can distribute this to verify
that so this
this is also
a valid expression let's do a couple
more of these
fill in the blank to produce an
expression equivalent to mu plus mu plus
mu well if i have i have three muse
right over here so this is literally
just going to be three
mu three times the variable mu that's
all that's going on right over there
let's do a couple more of this that was
pretty fast
which expressions are equivalent to six
l plus five m minus three n mark all
that apply
so let's look at this first one if i
were to distribute the three i would get
six l minus three n
plus five
and that and that are equivalent if you
just change the order oh a plus 5m let
me be very careful here so if i were
distributed 3 6l minus 3n
plus 5m
and this expression and this expression
are going to be equivalent if you just
swap the negative 3m and the 5m which
you could completely do addition is
commutative it doesn't matter which
order you actually add in so this is
legitimate
now let's see 3n
3 and plus 6 l so already
something shady here here you have a
minus 3 enter you could view as a
negative 3 n here you have a positive 3
n and they don't fix it anywhere else so
this does not seem
like a legitimate expression and they
also have a negative five m while it was
a positive five m right over there so
that's definitely not the case
so here you have five m a positive five
m well you have a positive five m right
over there then you have plus six l
minus three n putting these parentheses
these are essentially
reassociating what operation i would do
first but you could actually remove the
parentheses here and it won't change it
won't change the value you can what you
could think about is distributing the
positive sign or distributing the
positive 1 here it would just become 5m
plus 6l minus 3n which is just a
reordering of this right over here but
it's completely legitimate so let me
write that right over there
and then they have 5l and if you
distribute this this would be 3m so they
mixed everything else this is mixed
everything up this is 6l this is a 5l so
this
this one right over here is
this one right over here is no good this
is a lot of fun let's keep going
if we take the expression
2 times a plus 2b in parentheses and
ignore the parentheses we can write
another expression 2a plus 2b if you
were to do that is 2a plus 2b equivalent
to 2 times a plus 2b in parentheses
so when they're saying all of this thing
over here they're saying hey look i'm
just this irresponsible mathematician
and i like to just ignore parentheses
without thinking about it fully
and i if i did i would just get 2a plus
2b can i do this and you might already
imagining based on the tone of my voice
what the answer is and to think about it
you just have to realize well look
you're multiplying 2 not just times the
a you're multiplying 2 times the entire
quantity a plus 2b you have to
distribute that too this is going to be
equal to 2 times a
plus 2 times 2b
2 times 2b which is equal to 2a plus 4b
so you can't just ignore that there 2a
plus 4b is very different than 2a plus
2b so are these two things equivalent no
no this is seriously irresponsible
mathematics